maria márcia é professora de português e
maria gil é trituradora participam no
projecto 10 por 10 promovido pela
fundação calouste gulbenkian com intuito
de envolver professores artistas e
alunos num trabalho de valorização dos
conteúdos curriculares gostariam de ver
e inverter a idéia de que só conseguimos
fazer algo com terminadas as condições
não gosto de não se inscrever
vamos inverter convosco maria barcelona
dirigiu ia rolar um dia e sua mulher
jill eu sou maria bárcia sempre nos
disseram que nós compreenderemos melhor
os textos que nos aparecem à frente e
escreveríamos melhores lições muito mas
esse foi a contar a nossa proposta é
utilizar a escrita como preparação para
tornar os melhores leitores ou seja
escrever pra ler melhor todos vocês já
devem ter sentido medo a angústia da
página em branco 1 luca e pronto uma
pergunta no teste não saber como começar
uma frase o técnico escolhido
penso que tente usar palavras caras pra
encher os estádios e como escrita não
foi embora fica ali o papel fixa
vocês têm vergonha de quem escreve e se
calhar até alguns jogos disse que não
sabia que não sabiam escrever e vocês
acreditaram nisso então melhor ficar
quieto e nunca arriscada mas escreve -
escreve então pensamos que a escrita é
como um desporto qualquer que temos que
ir aos trailers que temos que praticar
de alimentos e como em qualquer desporto
não começamos logo a correr a maratona
começarmos com textos curtos com as
palavras porque conhecemos falando sobre
aquilo que sabe há uns e da forma que
nos sentimos mais à tarde e depois é
importante ler em voz alta que
descrevemos pode ser na casa de banho
para os nossos amigos pro os nossos pais
quando chegam a casa e começa a cozinhar
pode ser o nosso irmão mais novo ou pode
ser sozinho nos nossos quartos mas é
importante ler aqui o escrevente em voz
alta
porquanto quando vemos em voz alta nós
percebemos como estruturamos o nosso
pensamento organizamos as nossas ideias
e se tornam se também mais flexíveis e
autocrítica e sasha
já somos capazes de corrigir o texto que
descrevemos a alterar pequenas partes e
torna o texto mais claro para nós e
produtos e à medida que vamos praticar
de escrita fiscal instalando nas nossas
vidas
o ato de ler também se transforma já
somos capazes de enfrentar tais
longuíssimos que aparecem nos manuais
escolares e mesmo tempo que os livros
que vocês sabem que são obrigados a ler
que os com mais de 500 páginas que os
livros que nós achávamos que era
impossível correr um pouquinho ser uma
seca por nós não íamos conseguir lançar
até ao fim mas quando vamos ler esses
livros acontece uma coisa incrível é
mori da escrita ativas
nós temos palavras que agora estamos ali
nós escrevemos mas dentro do contexto
nós a conhecemos estruturas de testes
semelhantes aos diferentes
vemos palavras escritas já mais
utilizadas no outro contexto e é muito
importante nós já conseguimos
identificar os estudos que o escritor
está a utilizar porque nós também já
utilizamos até o truque para fazer é
passar uma mensagem enquanto estivesse
escrevendo e então o a leitura de
repente nós estamos implicados na
leitura já não sentimos já não vamos
abrir um livro com aquela atitude eu não
vou ser capaz de ler isto não vai
apressar nada pelo contrário nós
percebemos que o país precisa de nós
leitores
o teste foi feito pra nós ora esta esta
nossa idéia de inverter a idéia é
compensar mas a escrita e leitura surgiu
de uma experiência e fizemos as duas é
como turma do 10º ano na escola
secundária padre antónio vieira em
lisboa
isto no âmbito do projecto que se chama
dez vezes desde
essa um calouste gulbenkian ora esse
projeto é quem é via design que
partilharam com dez pessoas a encher os
processos de trabalho de criação as suas
linguagens e os seus métodos para que os
de coisas pessoas pudessem utilizar na
sala de aula com os alunos para que
depois as matérias do secundário se
tornarem mais claras e mais
interessantes e foi assim que nos
conhecemos eu sou professora de
português ou atriz e encenadora de
teatro e por criar com a maria bárcia
alguns dos exercícios de das divas que
tudo isso para criar material próximos
espetáculos que normalmente não partem
juntas já prescrita ou de um guião que o
contrário nós temos que criar uma série
de exercícios que depois pode ser
utilizado o espetáculo final ou não e um
dos exercícios que partilha é foi este é
o que nós chamamos de um exercício de
memória e os alunos estavam vendados e
nós passávamos 5 chairs um pedaço da
plan um senso profundo antigo le jeune
chi eo epicentro e depois os alunos
tinham que escrever um texto curto é a
partir de um xaile do que tivesse
disputado um particular eu vou dizer que
este não consegue encher um o fla fez me
pensar num campo imenso espaço livre
onde apenas em que me encontrava eu
espaço verde com tantas opções variadas
coisas mas essencialmente o fla era dele
é esse de a luz do sol diretamente por
cima da minha cabeça fez lembrar quando
voto e passou pela orla
em suma não perceber nada de especial
este é um teste escrito por um aluno e
motivar por um destes é chávez foi
disputou esta memória
outro dos exercícios que fizemos podemos
aos alunos que trouxessem cinco
fotografias de sua infância e uma peça
de roupa e eles tiveram que criar um
mini álbum com essa integração fias e
tiveram que o jornal não criar o alvo
original de forma
gerir uma certa negativa como se
tivessem recontar uma história e depois
a escrever a legenda podendo funcionar
ou não a legenda e reinventar fotografia
no final fazia uma espécie de instalação
artística com roupa que era da sua
infância e ir cinco fotos e se o que
também fizemos para disputar esta
escrita espontânea curta rápida foi
geraldo tinha um espelho o espelho o
espelho do bolso e escreviam fazia o seu
autorretrato a partir da imagem que viam
refletida nos pai eu vou ler é o mais um
texto de uma aluna é esse eu eu não
preciso de uns pode perceber quem sou
não fiz um espaço para receber minha
cara posso ver fotos no reflexo da água
ou no vidro de uma janela com maquiagens
uma pessoa sem maquiagem talvez um
fantasma
não sou assim tão fácil essa maquiagem
apenas mentira faça jovem adulta e
faz-nos sentir criança novamente bom mas
quando é que vamos começar com esses
exercícios diários que nós nos propõe é
que isto é bonito mas por ser sim
carinho ridícula fora do contexto
quando estamos fora da sala de aula
sozinhos ou com um par de amigos e mexe
eu me parece importante frisar é que
perder o medo de perder o medo de pegar
uma caneta e começar ele não sabe o que
é ver por exemplo hoje em vez de
enviarem um e maio aos vossos sobre a
experiência do dia de hoje podem
inscrever um postal enviado podem também
por exemplo escrever uma carta para
vossos próprios daqui a dez anos pode
enfim fazer um diário de viagem de casa
à escola escola casa só como fraz manter
esse diário podem registar a nariz no ar
por exemplo que eu iria como se fossem
turistas aqui serem realistas na vossa
amizade e pistas na nossa cidade e
registarem não só que o que vemos também
que o cheiro eo que eu vá
podem escrever uma história a partir dos
remédios que têm no vosso telemóvel
tenho certeza que alguns davam grande
romance em vários looks
c e e olha e as idéias e imagino que
vocês tenham imensa se é mas é que o
quiche de queijo com esta experiência e
que com é com a 1 para o reequipamento a
escrita dos alunos tornaram muito mais
complexa lados
é com muito menos vergonha diz porém que
o que pensam e serem julgados pelas suas
próprias palavras e e jaru também
escrita por ser uma atividade natural e
te pedida porque vamos precisar dela
preto dudu e por exemplo nas nossas
vidas
os alunos também se tornaram melhores
leitores por conseqüência porque quando
abrir os livros também se identificam e
também reconhecem enquanto autores
e como foi divertido escrever e ler
também vai ser divertido
por isso a nossa idéia é que o
experimento é escrever e depois de ver
obrigada obrigada